so adam's first goes to france in 1778
uh hit the ship uh the the the ship that
he took and he went
with his uh his son john quincy adams he
took him
and the ship's main mast was struck by
a lightning bolt destroyed the main mast
and the ship could
could barely sail they were attacked by
the british navy
uh adams um you know who was
the most distinguished i mean i mean he
was the prized possession on the ship
that it was the responsibility of the
captain to make sure he got
adams to france adams insisted
on going above deck and and fighting
uh and um you know literally
cannonballs and we have a record of this
cannonballs were whizzing over adam's
head and the captain told
go go below deck and adams uh refused
he said if you know if other men are
going to fight and die
for the cause so will i
adam's greatest contribution to the
american revolution which has gone
entirely neglected by
by historians is uh
i mean the great moment of independence
is not july 4th it's actually
july 1st because that was the day when
arguments were going to be taken up in
the continental congress
for or against independence and
john dickinson who was from delaware
and who himself had been one of the
intellectual leaders
of the revolutionary movement up until
that point stood up
and gave a three-hour speech against
independence
dickinson was a kind of moderate or
cautious revolutionary we might say
after he sat down the room
fell silent and
everybody sort of very nervously looked
around the room
who would be the person to stand up and
argue
for independence because the person who
stood up to argue for independence
would be of course reported to george
the third as the man who's making
the argument for independence and which
poser just said
what was dickinson's argument basically
that just we shouldn't do this now
because it's out because he was a
revolutionary i mean like he would have
wanted freedom right
yeah oh for sure absolutely um
he was a reconciliationist he he didn't
he thought that that patriot
revolutionaries
like john adams and his cousin samuel
adams
uh were pushing too hard too fast and
that there was still time
for reconciliation um
and but uh the adams cousins
uh and thomas jefferson as well and
george washington interestingly enough
um they they believed but and this is
particularly now in the light of
concord and lexington right concord and
lexington had been
had taken place in i think april uh
1775 the year before so armed conflict
had already begun
in in in the colonies in massachusetts
in particular
when we'd already had the battle of
bunker hill and
all that stuff so bloodshed had already
happened so
at this point for adams the rubicon
rubicon had been crossed certainly with
the battles in in massachusetts the
rubicon was passed
and he was full full steam ahead for
for independence so
in this in in in the congress meeting in
philadelphia
um you know everybody's very nervously
looking around the room right who you
know
who is going to be the man to stand up
and
be um and uh
and essentially be committing treason
because if this doesn't go your way
you're essentially designing your own
death warrant
at a certain level yeah certainly your
political life and probably your
real life yeah no that's exactly right
but then all eyes eventually turned on
the one man who they knew
would stand up the one man who had the
integrity
the honor and the courage and of course
was john adams
and john adams stood up and he gave
this kind of fiery argument for
independence
spoke for i think an hour and a half um
thomas jefferson described this speech
uh as as having he said quote
moved us from our seats and he described
adams
as the colossus of
of independence another delegate
who was there and witnessed adam's
speech described adams as the
atlas of independence and so i think in
many ways
well in fact not in many ways i'll just
say it i think this is the greatest
speech in american history
it's the most consequential speech in
american history now i see why you
didn't want me to skip right over to vp
right
yeah exactly and then the next day
the congress votes votes for
independence
um so adam's and then during this whole
period from
from let's say 75 to 77 now post
post independence adams
was he was a workaholic and
as i said he served on 90 committees
most importantly he served
he was the president of the board of war
and ordinance
which means that he he logistically ran
the war
uh so his job was to supply
uh washington's army uh with supplies
uh and it was you know it was more than
a full-time job
during that time he and by the way it
was john adams
uh who nominated george washington to be
commander
of of the american forces during this
time
adams uh also uh developed
uh what was known as the model treaty
which was this
which which became uh the the most
influential
um uh treaty uh or model of a treaty
almost throughout all of american
history because it argued that america
should never have
what it called entangling alliances so
adams was i mean i mean he was the most
active uh and principled revolutionary
during this time and you have to also
keep in mind
and this really is extraordinary he's
living apart from his
wife and young young family uh
i mean he was away from them for
almost two years he rode
by horseback round trip
from boston to philadelphia almost
always in the dead of winter
a two-week trip five times during
during this period um so i mean he i
mean he really was
yeah the work engine of the revolution
and then now
fast forward to the late 1770s
he was appointed by the continental
congress
as a minister of plenipotentiary to
go to europe and help try and get
france to uh ally with
uh with these now rebel uh americans
that couldn't have been a fun job well
it's extraordinary i mean it
i mean the stories that i'm about to
share with you i mean are
literally unbelievable and it tells you
everything you need to know about the
man john adams
so adam's first goes to france
in 1778 uh the ship
uh there the the ship that he took and
he went with his uh
uh his uh son john quincy adams he took
him
and the ship's main mast was struck by
a lightning bolt destroyed the main mast
and the ship
could could barely sail they were
attacked
by the british navy uh adams
um you know who was the most
distinguished
i mean i mean he was the prize
possession on the ship that
it was the responsibility of the captain
to make sure he got adams
to france adams insisted on going above
deck
and and fighting uh and um
you know literally cannonballs and we
have a record of this cannonballs were
whizzing over adam's head and the
captain told
go go below deck and adams uh refused
he said if you know if other men are
going to fight and die
for the cause so will i wow
so he goes to france he's he's only
there for six months as we're called
comes back and then is uh told now that
he has to go to france again
uh one more time uh and by the way you
have to remember he's doing a north
atlantic
crossing uh in these
leaky leaky rickety old ships
the second trip to france and this is
this is really
extraordinary he decides now he's going
to take
two of his sons uh john quincy who's 12
and charles who is eight three days
outside of boston
uh the ship uh is in a major storm a
three-day storm it springs a leak
all hands on deck have to pump water for
two weeks
uh and and this is in the middle of a
war uh and britain has the largest most
powerful navy in the world
uh so they have to sail basically
through uh through
the british black blockade the ship
was supposed to sail to bordeaux france
it can't make it to bordeaux
so it goes to the northwestern corner of
spain
el faro spain where adams and his two
sons disembarked adams now has a choice
he can wait a month for the ship to be
repaired to sail to bordeaux
or john adams
and his 12 year old and eight-year-old
sons decide
that they're going to take the overland
route and so
adams and his two boys set off on
donkeys
unbelievable and ride from west to east
across northern spain
they then and and along the way they're
staying
in in spanish boarding houses
can you imagine what a a bor a spanish
border boarding house in northern
uh spain in the 18th century would be
like adams describes that
they had they had fireplaces with no
chimneys
and the all the animals slept in the
houses so he it's extraordinary yeah
at one point you know they have to cross
the pyrenees
in the middle of the winter john quincy
adams in the diary
says that at one point going over the
mountains
on donkeys we were perpendicular right
they eventually get over the pyrenees
mountains and again
i mean imagine an eight-year-old and a
twelve-year-old an eight-year-old and a
twelve-year-old
riding donkeys across the pyrenees
mountains in the middle of the winter
they come over and they get into france
they get into a little village
called saint john de luz and from there
they take a coach and four
uh as it was called um to paris
a thousand mile trip how long did this
whole thing take
it took um i think it took them a month
so basically he could have waited oh i
guess waited a month for repairs and
then still had to sail
yeah got married the day before or
something yeah it might it might have
been two months i i don't remember now
but
i mean it's an extraordinary story and
it demonstrates
adams's commitment to the revolutionary
cause
right that and and it tells us something
about his moral character right that he
was willing
to do just about anything and everything
uh
for the sake of the american revolution
um
so he gets to paris um and
uh adams was not the most diplomatic
um of amer of america's revolutionary
diplomats
right by contrast benjamin franklin and
thomas jefferson
uh were the epitome of diplomacy as
defined by the french
but yankee john who was
honest to a fault um he just
he couldn't play the diplomatic game is
thomas jefferson the ambassador at this
time no jefferson is not jefferson is
not
quite yet in france jefferson will come
a few years later okay but franklin
uh franklin was there okay yeah so uh
adams was not a great
success at the court of of
louis xvi um so
he decided he would leave france and
instead go to the netherlands
where he conducted what he called
militia
diplomacy uh and
he he spent the first the first year
trying to get the dutch dutch bankers to
um commit to funding the american
revolution which he was successful at
doing
uh and then he finally got uh the dutch
government
to to recognize the the american the
american revolution
and during that that that i think two
three year period that he was in holland
i mean he was he was a a workaholic i
mean he's working now
seven days a week he's working 16 hour
days
he actually got malaria and was deathly
ill
uh during his time there um but it was
his performance uh as a european
diplomat
despite the fact that he broke all the
rules of diplomacy
despite the fact that he you know that
he was not a
let's call it a a manicured diplomat
i mean he got the bottom line is he got
the job done
and then he is appointed
to be the first ambassador to the court
of st james in britain so he goes
he goes to britain in uh i think 1785
um where he serves as uh
the diplomat uh america's ambassador uh
to to britain and if i could one more
yeah one more quick story which i again
i'm i'm trying to
um uh share with you and your audience
um the extraordinary character of this
man yeah well that's i like
that we're getting a sense of the real
real person here and not just the
political philosophy
yeah yeah so uh in
1780 in 1784-85 um
he'd already made several north sea
crossings
in the winter which is a brutal crossing
to have to make
and he has to go back one last time to
secure
more loans from dutch bankers
and he boards ship he's deathly ill but
he does it
and again a day out of
out of port the ship hits a massive
storm and
they are the the ship gets close to
holland but is effectively shipwrecked
on a deserted dutch island
and adams uh and and
his the crew they get out on this island
they trekked and adams is now i mean i
you know he's close to 50. and they had
to
trek uh break snow
knee-deep snow for eight miles
to get to uh a small village where they
got a car which took them to the far end
of the island
they get to the far end of the island
then they have to rent
ice boats because the channel between
the island and the mainland
is filled with ice and these ice boats
have runners
on the bottom of them right so they row
row where there's water until they get
to ice
right and then somebody has to get out
pull
the boat up onto the ice then they have
to walk across
ice and then they get to water again
then they have to get back in the boat
the boat goes back into the water
and they and and then they have to
repeat this you know let's say five
times ten times over wow
um but again it it it just
that kind of story i think demonstrates
the man and you have to understand the
man
in contrast to to say other
revolutionaries
thomas jefferson for instance
essentially sat out the war
after um he wrote the declaration of
independence
he left philadelphia and basically lived
at monticello
for the rest of the war he was governor
of virginia for a couple of years um
but that was it and so sat out the war
whereas adams was
more with the exception i guess of
george washington was more intimately
involved
in in the everyday workings of the
revolution than any other
american revolutionary at the time if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell